i want to uh address something that a
lot of people
are uh talking about
and it is it is about race and it is
about
changing our society and it's about
holding people accountable
and that's something that i've become
[Music]
uh more open to in the past week you
know holding people accountable i don't
i don't think
i i've been really um
excited and i think that is the right
word by the amount of people
who are outing themselves as problematic
and i've been i've been excited by it
because i think that's the first step to
really healing and creating
an equitable society the first step is
for people
to come out um jenny slate comedian
writer uh the show big mouth
uh jenny slate is a white woman
and she played the role of a character
named missy
on big mouth an animated show on netflix
and missy was a mixed race character who
had a jewish white mother like slate
and a black father i mean clearly we're
looking at missy here missy is clearly
black
even though she's mixed race but you
know
jenny slate has recused herself from the
show
and she's leaving because she said
um black characters should be played by
black people
i don't think that's enough
okay she's contributed to the erasure
of black people and she's said that she
said she erased the black prayer i don't
even know what that is
i don't know what futuristic weapon what
ray gun
she used to erase a black person but i
don't think it's enough
to just say sorry and go back to your
mansion no thank you ma'am
jenny slate has to go to jail
she has to be brought up on charges and
she has to go to jail
for no less than 10 years
for what she did this is not a [ __ ]
joke
stop laughing you white pig
she needs to hear every night
she needs to hear the bars clink
she needs to lose her freedom what has
she done with her freedom
she's used it to erase black people
by voicing the character a mixed-race
character on big mouth on netflix
no thank and cancel big mouth while
we're at it
good sorry nick kroll cancel big mouth
you're gonna have to get a job with your
family
doing security related matters
i'm sorry i don't i don't want to be
this way but i am
i don't want to be this way but i am
jenny said i have come to the decision
today that i can no longer play the
character of missy
on the animated tv show big mouth at the
start of the show i reasoned with myself
that it was permissible to play missy
because her mom is as jewish and white
as am i
but missy is also black and black
characters on an animated show
should be played by black people i
acknowledge how my original reasoning
was flawed
that it existed as an example of white
privilege and an unjust allowances made
within a system of societal white
supremacy
and that me playing missy was engaging
in an act of erasure of black people
put her in jail now
put her in jail put her in jail
why is she not in jail
one of the producers of this show not
behind
bars god damn them
god damn her god god sam
i'm only i am not i'm only laughing now
because i'm so angry yeah that when i
laugh i get i i get i get angry and i
laugh
but i god damn them black lives matter
do you understand that they matter on a
netflix cartoon
put her in jail that nick kroll's
parents built
not even the not even a i mean an
underground prison
what do we not know what they do use
google dummies
i get it she's got to go to jail
a secret underground facility where she
can be re-educated
not my fault
i want to hold people accountable
they're being held accountable this week
that's it no more games this week
tim is here to hold everyone accountable
will i apologize for the bid i did with
nick mullen
where we said that orthodox jews were
wearing diapers to
to uh landlord tenant court because they
were pretending to be insane
so they could continue to rip off their
minority tenants i will not apologize
for that
that i will not do because i did not
erase a black person in that
if anything i called attention to
inequality with that
you see the difference
i've had enough for too long i've sat on
the sidelines
while cartoonists have destroyed the
fabric of american society
we cannot tolerate this anymore
most importantly though jenny says to
anyone that i've hurt i am so very sorry
oh i bet that feels good i am so very
sorry
how many people have killed themselves
because of this how many lives have
ended because of your show i bet
it's unquantifiable how many people
killed themselves
put a gun in their mouth jumped off a
building
cut their own throat maybe their wrist
od on
bills took a hair dryer and electrocuted
themselves in the tub
asphyxiated themself hung themselves
i bet all of these black people that are
dying tragically
with nooses they are hanging themselves
because they found out that missy was
voiced by jenny slate
that is that is a hypothesis i have it
is not proven it is a hypothesis
but i think it's pretty damn good
so i'm i'm i'm asking miss slate ms
slate and the and the producers of big
mouth
to turn themselves in to the military
not even the lapd
those corrupt bastards no the military
to be to have a tribunal
we need a military tribunal in this case
they will not have a jury of their peers
they will be tried by a jury of
of people that are selected the people
that have been affected
the people that have been affected
failed comedians will judge her
comedians that don't make any money will
judge miss slate
people that have podcasts that have 45
uh
reviews on apple will stand the judgment
of miss slate
mr kroll and the entire show
they will judge you and i hope explain
it to them
explain it to the people that couldn't
even
get a [ __ ] free drink for their
horrible comedy and have wasted their
entire lives those are the people you
have to convince
and the death penalty is not off the
table
i'm not saying it's going to be i'm not
it is
it is a tool it should be available to
the prosecution
that's what i'm saying here i'm done
letting people off
this by the way what i'm doing here is
what everyone's gonna have to do
this is the new strategy with woke
people is to go more woke than they are
this is the new strategy like when they
say we should take down that monument
you go we should nuke an american city
that's what you say if someone says no i
want to get rid of this monument go
let's
nuke dc let's nuke washington
you gotta you uh because you gotta they
gotta look at you like
huh like it's it's gotta be so bad now
like when they
when she steps down a big mouth i go we
shouldn't have a big mouth it's gotta go
it's tainted it's over it's over
that's what you're going to have to do
you're just going to have to when
somebody says to you
when somebody starts a conversation and
goes listen
why not get rid of all these monuments
go i and i will do you one better
i will do you one better why not get rid
of them all at once
let's nuke washington dc
let's get a suitcase nuclear weapon and
and and and nuke washington dc
and if they if they're shocked by that
or they argue against that you just look
at them and go huh
oh so you're gonna you're gonna take uh
the monuments that are offensive and
leave the white house
and uh congress and the washington
monument
and what no no no no no no
we're going to nuke the capital
that is the woke position
and when things get and then and when
things get better when the radiation is
gone in a few months or years i don't
know
then we will go and build an equitable
society but we're not we're not going to
do these surgical strikes
we're not going to do these surgical
strikes we're going in with a suitcase
snoke
we're going in with a sugar snook and
jenny slate will be publicly executed
for what she has done to the black
community yes or yes
yes or yes don't get that that's the
great derral davis
drunk uh uh real estate uh uh
motivational speaker in long island
would say
yes or yes don't give them don't give
them the chance to say no